this works
hi um
my name is chen and i'm currently a
postdoc at stanford working on
interactive robot learning and also i
graduated from ut austin last year and
it's interesting we're in the same like
uh panel but yeah i actually was part of
that uh reviewing committee
uh for for two years and yeah if you're
interested i can talk about my
experience there but yeah anyway that's
not gonna be my talk today
so um today i'm going to give you a
brief overview of what i work on and
then zoom into a particular project that
i think is
going to be of interesting for the
discussion within this workshop
so i work with robots and
industrial robots have
revolutionized manufacturing in the past
50 or so years
and they are often tasked to work
in a fixed environment uh and on a
single and very specific task
so when we think about bringing the same
level of automation uh into
human-centered environment
like hospitals hotels and our own homes
new challenges arise
so the first one being that now the
environment we expect these robots to
work in are going to be unstructured
dynamic and diverse
and um
so
how do we tackle this uh let's give them
the ability to adapt and learn after
deployment
so we think about the problem of robot
learning uh considering three different
entities the human user the robot and
the environment
the robot takes actions that changes the
state in the environment and receives
consequent observations from the
environment team
so
since it's becoming possible for a robot
engineer to start program the robot for
every
single like possible scenarios the robot
is gonna
need to work with
we we have a human user calming mind um
so they they usually come with the task
they want the robot to do in mind and in
order uh to actually allow the robot to
adapt to the environment after
deployment we can leverage this human
user to provide data to the robot
and traditionally this is in the form of
demonstrations
so traditional learning from
demonstration methods allow a user to
program robots by providing kinesthetic
demonstrations which is physically
moving the robot or tally of operative
robot uh like um using some
controller
uh or nowadays even vr to control the
robot
however i i would argue that
providing these kind of demonstrations
is a high effort form of teaching
and
um
when robots nowadays are faced with
non-expert human users
this kind of high-effort form of
teaching is not no longer user-friendly
so
the research i've been uh working on
focuses around this problem this
question of how can we enable robot
learning from low effort form of human
teaching
and
in order to do that we think about this
uh human
robot learning problem
um by enabling the robot to take an
active role in this learning in its own
learning process so and enable this
interaction between the robot and the
human user
so the robot can
provide
queries to the human user and receive
feedback
such that it makes better use of the
human user's effort
and
formally
the problem of robot learning is often
modeled as
markov decision processes where the
robot has a set of possible states and a
set of possible actions it can take to
move in between these states
the state transition dynamics
dedicates how the robot moves from one
state to another given an action
and um lastly we really have this notion
of a reward function that actually
defines the task the robot is uh
it needs to learn and the the robot has
a policy that maps states to actions and
the goal of the robot is to
learn a policy that
in expectation
the
maxim maximizes the accumulated reward
over time
so when when a human
user comes into picture um in practice
oftentimes we don't actually have this
reward function from the environment
uh
and rather that this reward function is
somewhere in the human's mind
we make this assumption that what the
human desires can be captured by some
underlying reward function but it
doesn't necessarily mean the human
actually knows through over function
so the
now the goal of the robot becomes to
learn this policy
uh from interaction with the human who
actually may not even observe this
reward function themselves
so um in a recent survey paper um with
collaborating with colleagues in
carnegie mellon we are thinking we are
trying to argue that in order to analyze
the effect of
an interaction design on the learning
outcomes
we need to think about how interaction
design
affect the training data we generate for
these robots
and we argue that there are two pathways
one is direct
which is the optimal informativeness of
an interaction query assuming we can re
receive expert feedback this is what we
designed the interaction to be so as an
engineer we proposed an algorithm we
know what kind of questions the robot
can pose to the human and in what form
we're receiving these
feedback
so and we can um
optimally compute like what's more
informative given model meters
however um
there is another pathway that
once we design this interaction it has
an effect on the human user and that
effect is indirect and oftentimes much
more complex
than what we can imagine at the time we
designed the the the algorithm
and
um
for these uh two reasons
um
it's it's not easy to actually uh design
a perfect interaction
that that will work with any any user at
test time
so the work i uh did throughout my phd i
tried to
tackle the the problem of learning from
lower for human teaching under both
pathways
under the first one
we think more about how we can generate
informative queries because this is
direct we can just find a metric we want
to optimize
and then think about how we pro
how we develop an algorithm to actually
optimize for that metric
and in the direct pathway we need to
think about how this
interaction design actually has an
effect on the human user who's gonna
actually interact with the robot
and from that end uh
i've proposed different
forms of interactions that the user can
use to interact with the robot
so for the rest of the talk today i'm
actually going to focus on just one
project
that's on the idea of learning from
implicit human feedback
so this is a collaborative work with
chipping alessandro peter scott and brad
and at that time we were like associated
with ut bosch
and some of us with wash
so the idea of natural uh increased
human feedback is that
humans naturally react when we watch
other agents perform tasks
and
um for for a learning agent when when it
sees other humans react to uh its
performance can it actually leverage
their reactions to learn something about
their children performance
so we proposed this um learning
framework
evaluate evaluative mapping for
effective task learning from human
inclusive use
showed it as empathic it has two stages
in the first stage the robot learns
a mapping from implicit human feedback
to a fixed set of task statistics we
designed
and the the important part of the first
stage is that
since we design the task we need to
incentivize
the the human user to actually align
their internal uh
like valuation of the task with what we
specified the
uh the task to be
so once we do that we um yeah actually
in our specif like to give you a
concrete example in our user studies we
just tell our participants that
their payout for participating in our
user study is going to be proportional
to the performance of e-robot
so that's the the the incentive uh
incentive uh yeah that's how we
incentivize the the our participants and
once we have that we can actually record
data
um
and learn this mapping of reaction
features to task statistics
so that at a time test time given a
deployment task
without any task specifications we can
just learn from observing the reaction
of a human
so this is the model we
instantiated the empathic framework with
and more specifically we were looking at
learning from human uh facial actions
um so we record videos of our
participants and then we extract the
features like their official uh action
activations and as well as the
uh frequencies of the feature movement
in the horizontal and vertical
directions so those will
correspond with a head motion
of like knot and shakes
and with this model we were able to
learn a mapping in a simulated task and
then transfer that to this robotic trash
sorting domain
and
um
yeah hopefully
there is also some
so
okay that's it so with this model we
learned we were actually able to uh rank
the trajectories in this particular
robot trash sorting domain so all the
ones uh color green actually resulted in
um
positive returns like the one i just
showed so it sorted the the correct
object and the line was red it sorted
the wrong object the ones with yellow it
just didn't end up picking up any object
so we see that by just looking at the uh
facial reactions of these participants
we were able to tell the the ones color
green should be ranked higher than the
ones colored colored uh yellow or red
so
from this project actually we realized
there are so many challenges just in
designing effective user studies and i'd
like to share some of that with you all
today i think that i think that's more
relevant to the discussion of this
workshop
the first one being that
um
like
human subjects are very complex and
their behaviors shift uh when even a
single like factor of the condition
changes
and it's well known that when subjects
are aware that they're part of study
their behaviors
may become different from when they are
naturally interacting with robots
so
this this is kind of like
conflicting with what we uh initially
like targeted for it because we actually
want to be able to learn from natural
human reactions
um but once we put humans in this uh
study room and putting a camera in front
of them they start to become aware of
how their data is going to be used
i don't know if
that was the reason that they were so
reactive to our agents or that's the
reason that they wasn't uh behaving very
uh naturally um
but we we see a lot of challenges of
basically deploying this model outside
of the elaborated lab settings
and
another issue is that um while we tried
our best to incentivize our participants
oftentimes they are not as invested in
the task or they don't care about the
robot performance as much as we want
them to do
and we also learn this by trying to do
the same task through mechanical turk
like during the pandemic
and it turns out like antarctica's are
just trying to maximize their throughput
of tasks so that they can maximize their
payout at the end of the day
they sometimes don't even pay attention
uh to the tasks where we were showing
them uh during the study
and last but not the least that uh is
the fact that like humans are highly
adaptive
and um their interaction
the interaction dynamics between the
human and robot may change over
long-term interactions between them
and this is basically saying that our
model learned today may not be
applicable in the long run
because as a society we are getting more
and more familiar with robots and our
reactions to their behaviors can change
over time you probably were surprised
the first time you saw a roomba moving
but but not like 50 times after
so with that um i'd like to mention two
future directions i'm good on time okay
yeah
and uh the first one being developing
foundation models for robots so i've
been talking about this with want a form
of low effort
teaching
and a lot of that needs the robot to do
a lot of learning ahead of time and that
that's the idea
where we
adapt existing large-scale language and
vision models for the robot to do
semantic understanding so that hopefully
one day it can start taking natural
language instructions and ground that to
its own
actions so we no longer need to provide
physical demonstrations
and
um yeah following that direction we
actually are interesting how do we do
online adaptations and personalizations
after the robots are deployed
um but actually uh give me one more
minute i'd like to
end on a note on uh human babies so i
recently became a mom and uh just
realized how helpless human beings are
when they are born
and by some
research estimation that a human mom
would have to go through a pregnancy
period of 19 to 21 months if the human
baby is to be born at the same
developmental stage as a chimpanzee
newborn
so some uh
biologist swiss biologist
adam portman uh hypothesized that human
beings are born so early because they
need to embed their their like
developmental processes
in interactions
so learning from interactions is an
important part of human intelligence
and yeah i'd like to just undo it
thanks
you can keep that mic on
thanks my questions for you chen um you
know you started off by talking about
how robotics and automation had
revolutionized manufacturing in the last
half century or so and then said that
the challenge is how do we adapt that to
an environment that's unstructured
dynamic and diverse in you know domestic
spaces and all that
and they got me thinking that like
it's not a state of nature for labor to
be
structured
stable and homogeneous like that's a
design choice and a managerial and
political strategy like that doesn't
just happen by accident and so i'm
wondering if in moving i mean what
you're talking about is automation
essentially if we're moving automation
into domestic spheres is there a chance
that that certain design values
managerial strategies political choices
get imported over there so rather than
the robots simply adapting to
a static state of nature which is more
diverse and different that we're
actually changing the nature of the
space in which those robots or
automation aren't happening if that
makes sense yeah
what should i yeah
oh yeah yeah so yeah that's an excellent
question so um but for me i think more
of it as should we um adapt
robot to human environment or we should
actually adapt human to robots and uh or
like in more well relevant to the
autonomous like uh very close like
should we actually building
infrastructures that
they operate more smoothly or we
actually make them to work with what we
have currently so i think um
like if possible
things should go both ways like
um if if you look at how like amazon
have these
home robots they they are they're trying
to um
sell to a selected set of customers and
there they're trying to filter like what
kind of home you have whether you have
glasses at a large window at home that
the robot cannot perceive or like how
big is your floor and whether you have
small bumps that that the robot cannot
roll over so they they're doing these
things already like by trying to
um filter what the the the target of
deployment domain is but what i'm trying
to argue is that at the end of the day
your robot is uh going to
interact uh with a human uh that that's
going to use it and um since like at
that point like the robot might be
tasked to do something that the human
have specific in mind they need these uh
learning abilities to adjust to their
user's preference
um one example i could give is like even
for autonomous driving
um this is really like just speaking up
from personal experience like
um me and my husband we drive this uh
tesla and we
actually whenever we turn on the
autonomous driving we each have a
different way of trying to um like with
different ways of feeling uncomfortable
with it it tries to dry in the middle of
the road which actually is nice but for
me i prefer to drive a little bit closer
to the left because i feel like i react
faster uh to the end
i'm closer with but my husband actually
has this preference of driving to the uh
right because that's much uh he he feels
like it's it's much likely to apply uh
with like uncommon tests from the other
side so like users have drastically
different preferences uh with autonomous
very very close so yeah i don't know if
that actually answers the question but
that's yeah talk about it after perhaps
now we might take uh
actually probably still one at a time
okay great
um yeah thanks for two really really
great papers uh my questions for you
chad as well
um so you just in your reply right now
you mentioned you know should we adapt
robots to humans or might we need to
adapt humans a little bit to robots
write it as a back and forth uh process
or like
two directional uh two-directional
process so i'm wondering if you could
could talk a little bit more about
how would it ever be possible to
disentangle
reactions
of humans towards robots from
uh you know natural reactions because
you know in the scenarios that you
described you see people you know in
these very contrived uh artificial
scenarios you talked about that right
but um you know how can you ever
disentangle this like how can you ever
produce
a data set of natural reactions in an
artificial setting as a baseline for
then you know building onto
that makes sense
yeah yeah i think um
so that
i don't want this to sound like
um
unethical but like i feel like we really
need data set in the natural settings
but like the problem is that we don't
already have robots interacting with
robots from on a daily basis
that's that's the
um that's the target like deployment
setting so um it's
like some of this we might need to come
from like uh studying human human
interactions so by just understanding
how human uh pick up signals from each
other maybe in a like more theoretical
and generative way you can build these
more um
i say like parametrize models by
understanding our own interactions and
use that for the robot and once we have
that robot we can start collecting like
data sets that's more um natural like
once it's already deployed uh in
interacting with the human and there
like there's still this controversy of
like whether we should actually let the
human know the ways the robot is
processing their data and
if whether
the human is going to be comfortable
with that
um or not but like at that point i feel
like that that's gonna be the new norm
like that's basically the way we're
interacting with our cell phones and the
way we're interacting with uh tvs
nowadays
and um and those
like at some point that's gonna become
more or less stable and all and also if
we like make robots like personalizable
and
uh adapt to individual differences
at that point we can start to rely on
the data
we receive
so yeah so that's that's the hope
so my questions for serena and i'm so
the using the machine learning and
applications of course anyone who who's
in admissions would could see the burden
of going through that but
and i know you didn't have the full
justice of time to really present the
case but was it that the quote about
being shocked
isn't did they not do anything like take
50 of the applications and try it with a
new procedure and just kind of have any
tests of how
the performance was versus the
unassisted human by not giving it the
ranking i'm just incredulous by by this
case
yeah that's a that's an excellent
question so i want to preface by saying
that like i think um probably going to
the original paper is
like better source material and like
full details of that but um they and
yeah maybe actually chen might even know
about the the
i mean my
my view of it is only from the lens of
that paper i wasn't actually inside the
the room when any of the decisions were
made but um in the paper they do talk
about ways that they
trying to go about that validation
process so i think they did do some kind
of test where they like split up some of
the applications for like just human
review and then some for like human plus
the
um
the like grade review and then i think
they compared those somehow and looked
at like oh compared to like the just
human review was grade say under
predicting or was it over you know where
were the errors like were the errors in
the region where grade was predicting
like really low or were they where it
was breaking time so i i don't remember
the exact like
numbers that they came up with but that
is like a kind of study that they did
back in like
i think this was like in the early times
when they were just putting it out
sorry but it also seems like just when
you give a ranking that's like with the
other some of the other half of the
right itself must start to
really
form the decision making so i just
wondered if they
anyway absolutely fascinating thank you
yeah i mean that's like also totally an
excellent point and at some point like
there is
like
i think there's something to be said
about the fact that like we don't we
won't ever actually know the real
counter factual there like what actually
would have happened if this wasn't um
there and also things were changing over
time so like some of these things are
like something that i wish we could
answer but like i don't
know that we can now
thanks
yeah i'm back to youtube although i
think this question may also have
implications for serena and i'm picking
up on lee's
question
trying to relate
these talks to the theme of our cluster
which is
um
[Music]
great to hear about the technology
let's now focus back on to the human
and assumptions about the human but it
isn't just like the human user that
that's a very generic
characterization and it's very rare
in real life
that it's simply the user even even that
term is it just wipes out so much that's
important from a political
ethical point of view so back to lee's
question about
labor if you're
a worker in a factory and this is your
livelihood
and the factory owner says
i want you to suggest so or like you're
an uber driver because you know that's
another case we want to learn from you
how to automate vehicles so we can put
you out of a job
the owner says
sit just so
and you know don't move because we're
observing your behavior so that the
robot can learn well
now you're in a home and with the best
of intentions you can you're saying
let's adapt this environment but it's
all a market right so
we know that if
if a family is told
do this just so so our robot can learn
you're probably not going to get uh
cooperation
so now when you and and the motive that
you give
um your motive for doing certain things
or
serena your motive for doing certain
things and i had said a similar thing
yesterday
fabulous
this is why you're
doing the work you're doing
but i want to ask both of you to think a
little bit more about
what it could mean
if that user isn't
like a free agent
maybe a teacher
um
who
or an admissions person and actually
we're going to use this algorithm to
just you know get rid of your jobs
completely and so
etc so this is
i want to ask you to please think about
it or tell us who should be thinking
about this
your best position because you know the
thing
i can take this first so i i completely
agree that we should be uh actually
thinking about this
uh these questions and especially when
we
actually go about deploy uh these robots
like there should be discussions around
like what happens if something goes
wrong like the same with autonomous
driving so
at the policy level like when you tackle
knowledge like um
it gets deployed we should discuss the
harms of it
but i also want to take the
view that like jobs are being taken for
sure but like if you think about it um
computers used to be
jobs like there used to be people
actually doing this computing um for
like for the purpose of um i don't know
other projects um they are slowly
replaced with the technology but not
that's not mean that that there are just
a lot of people on out of jobs we adapt
like the society did adapt over like
long
period of time like over decades
and these people get trained to do other
tasks and they may have new jobs like um
maybe teleoperating in the robot uh in
this case like teaching them how to do
these tasks and um
and as a matter of fact a lot of like
uh countries like japan they are
actually suffering from the the lack of
like a labor like um they have so many
elderlies that need to be taken care of
that they just don't have enough um
young people and that's why they have
the
densest like robot uh
actually population right now as
nowadays they they are developing these
technologies so that they can automate
uh home care for for their elderly's
so i think um
yeah that it is a problem that like we
should constantly think about like the
harm we bring as we design technology
um
but like humans are highly adaptive at
the same time and oftentimes uh when we
look back we see that um as a society
and because we are here and you are here
we we are adapting uh yeah
i don't know if that that that actually
seriously can ask you to respond as well
yeah of course yes um yeah thank you so
much for that great point because um i
want to like man i wish i had more time
today but actually a lot of what we do
try to say in our paper is that like
a lot of the like machine learning for
education papers that we studied like i
think they exactly suffer from this
issue of like
not humanizing like the or not thinking
enough about like the depth of the the
different like people in the system so
one i'm going to point out like two
examples that i wish i could have talked
about or like that you know we'll have
in more detail in the paper so one is
that like in a lot of these like
automated systems they tend to want to
like
you know summarize numerically a lot of
like inherently qualitative or human
traits that like you can't
you know really just like put in it's
like trying to like rate a painting on a
scale of one to ten or like rate
somebody's like life story on a scale of
you know zero to one like that doesn't
really that kind of like quantitative
summary of these like complex and
qualitative
um
elements or human pieces is like
uh
not something that we should take for
granted or like we um you know we should
be careful once it like when those
things
kind of get
suggested in the form of these kinds of
like quantitative um
or technological choices
um and i don't even know if like
even with the best of intentions these
things might just kind of accidentally
get suggested um so then another thing
that i would that i also want to point
out is that um
in the like translation between from
these like
quantitative predictions to
interventions there's like one kind of
thing that uh repeatedly came up in our
interviews was that it's important to
like keep uh like the best success comes
from actually like
incorporating human operators in the
process or like designing
with um their kinds of different
strengths so
um
one example was that like when they had
uh
when chat bots were deployed in like an
advise an advising
system at a university
for for somebody we interviewed they
actually like they found that if a
student just kind of used that chat bot
like the student doesn't know what they
don't know so you know they could only
answer like very specific small
questions or like ask
you know specific kind of almost
logistical questions but when they
actually had the advisor involved in the
process and the advisor could have these
like um you know in-depth conversations
with the student and kind of like elicit
what kinds of uh needs the student
really had then the chatbot was actually
able to
you know assist the advisor in pointing
out like oh um you know maybe the
student might struggle with like these
classes or something and then the
advisor could come around and like
provide a better recommendation so
i think that the human element in
especially education systems is like
extremely important and essential to
think very critically about and
carefully
great thank you so much for um both of
these talks i
found them fascinating and i look
forward to talking to you both about
them more um my question is um for
serena actually and it's not the type of
question that i normally find myself in
the position of asking um but you know i
think for a lot of uh
people in this room like the idea of
like
there are these unattended consequences
of deploying this algorithm like it
ended up kind of potentially
exacerbating exactly the kind of
societal problems that
you know a lot of us think very
carefully and deeply about in our work
um
the the fact that in 2020 um ut austin
stopped using it is like
the first stop of a first step of a
success story like good job you're no
longer using the algorithm but i would
really and i know you sort of ran out of
talking about the second half of your
talk but it kind of strikes me as like
well what now because the underlying
pressures that drove them to adopt the
algorithm to begin with are all still
there um you know i have
um
dear friends of mine who are in postdocs
in michigan that there are they accept
three people a year and they get 900
applicants like
and if an algorithm isn't formalizing
that problem a little bit that's not to
say that humans aren't like whoever's at
the bottom of the pile at the end of the
night when you're sleepy and like hungry
like you're gonna be grumpier and have
low blood sugar and then they're
arbitrarily so i don't know like i i'm
i'm glad that they're no longer using a
potentially biased algorithm but the
underlying pressures
to deal with that problem and to try to
systematize it and to try to formalize
like a fairer way of of doing admissions
clearly all of that those pressures are
still there so i would just love to hear
you reflect on like where do we go like
what what's the next step
thank you for that question and serena
while you think about that we've got a
few more questions and i have one that
actually relates directly to that so i'm
going to add it and then we'll take the
remaining ones
together
so so my question is about
precisely this kind of the way in which
these automated systems
put pressure on and also expose value
preferences of institutions
so it's interesting that um in your in
the ais you're describing what we're
seeing is
the need to articulate clear goals right
and those somehow become public through
this process in a way that they might
not have before
so the question so this is interesting
and you had a quote from a student
saying you know
or a preference expressed by students
saying i would not want my application
to be processed this way
so my question is
have these models or have you
done any thinking about how you would
what kind of new pressure that is and
how you might engineer for those
preferences too
so how do you
articulate a public value
or what kinds of public value might be
there and what kinds of public value
might systems like that try to engineer
in
ben you're saying your questions on the
same topic okay let's add it let's have
it sorry everyone we're diluting the
questions
yeah i really think they're just
building off of one another but yeah i'm
interested in this like
it almost gets to the level of your
methodology of comparing the goals
stated in ml papers to the goals
that sort of come naturally out of
interviews with education practitioners
where there is sort of
a um
nice connection that you can make
between for example the
optimization like objective function and
a goal as articulated by an education
practitioner but i'm really interested
in like how that formulation
might break down or might not always
um
work as a as a comparison like to what
extent
to what extent are educational goals
like
not
uh
like are is it difficult to boil down
educational goals to an objective
function and sort of
as salome said like where do we go from
there like what do we do with that
i think education experts are often like
looking at the particular needs of
students and in much more communication
with students and so
the sort of like impersonal
approaches to machine learning might not
be fitting and is the answer just
refusal or is there anything we can do
with sort of
yeah the kind of scale and and
current state of education that we find
ourselves in
solve the world's problems now
oh boy i mean i think all three of you
just articulated like my entire research
agenda for the next thing
because i think these are i mean
first i want to say that like i think
our paper brings out a lot more
questions than answers so for sure like
i don't have
great answers for a lot of things you're
saying because i'm and i'm really
thinking about those things i want to
point out like
uh let's see one one thing i did want to
uh what i think is cool is that it seems
like you've keyed in on this like issue
of
um goals and how those goals
you know interact with
our technological solutions and the way
that we approach building these
especially specifically machine learning
technologies because that's where i uh
yeah focus so um there's two things two
directions that i've been thinking about
recently in that
um
in this like kind of translation gap
between the goals and the
technologies and the first is that like
um
the first is this kind of we have this
bias towards thinking that there's just
one goal or one objective to optimize in
um especially in machine learning
systems i mean the way these things are
built is you optimize an objective
function maybe subject to some
constraints but like there's one
objective function
um and
i think that this kind of uh
like
this oversimplification is
more common than we think or like it is
quite common but in practice like in
reality there's really like these very
complex environments with a lot of
different needs um
and
a lot of different goals that can always
be can't always be quantified so easily
so like one
um
one that's that's a kind of one issue
that i'm like thinking a lot about now
is like how do we how do we go from just
like trying to optimize one objective to
like
working within these like complex
multi-goal environments
um the second thing is that like maybe
the goals that we have access to are not
um
[Music]
are just a subset of like
like again this like broader ecosystem
of of different goals and objectives so
um even if we are if even if we do
consider like optimizing over
you know a subset of like some number of
goals that say i know about now like
is optimizing these really the best move
or is there some like
i mean because if you like in all these
machine learning papers they're just
like oh how do we like
get to optimality what is you know we
want like pareto optimality or just
different notions of it but like is that
really what we want to do even if we
like expand our number of objectives or
is there like something else that we
should be thinking about like maybe we
want to um
yeah and that's kind of like an open
like
question that i've also been
working on so i don't know if that quite
answered
your question of that's i think your
question of uh like
what the just because we remove a
technology doesn't mean like the problem
doesn't go away like that is
like
i totally empathize also with the fact
that like that isn't the question that i
would usually ask either but like i
think it's definitely like
um at play here especially with
education where like it's like you know
chronically under-resourced in a lot of
you know different places and areas so
um
i think before we can answer that
question well though there's like okay i
think there's still a lot of work that
needs to be done in the technological
space to like find where these gaps are
and where it's like
where it's kind of failing people um
in order to like
come back and be able to like actually
improve things
so i don't know i guess it's just an
ongoing iterative
thing and i don't have a great answer to
that question
thanks right so we've got um three
further
four now further questions we're gonna
take peter
julia and then
chris
and then jd in that order can we keep
the questions super brief without eating
into break time we did start a little
late
uh i feel like everyone's okay with that
go
this is a bit of a comment as well as a
question i think that
it seems that one of the presumptions
that's kind of behind this is the
objective function whether it's for
purposes of machine learning how to
engage with humans or in this education
context is the objective function seems
to be at the level of the provision or
the production of certain kinds of
behavior
so in education in our education about
providing education how fast the
students get through and all that but
there's also purposes of education
and those purposes of education extend
out over a long time horizon
so if you're asking what's the purpose
of education is it to ensure the kids
get grades is it about degrees is it
getting jobs is it about employment or
is it about opening up entirely new
kinds of opportunity pathways that
wouldn't have existed for them otherwise
and can we devise objective functions
that address those longer term purposes
because it gets back to a lot of the
other questions that we're talking about
here which are
we've got a human technology world
relationship that's developing over time
it's evolutionary and it's recursive
and we're transforming ourselves in that
process of deploying these technologies
we're not human beings we're human
becomings we're becoming moment by
moment changing as we interact with
these systems that we're deploying and
it's according to whose values
and with what timing
so the question is it's not just an
issue of
you know sort of which harms are going
to be incurred by human beings but whose
values are going to be shaping our human
becoming
[Music]
super super interesting stuff i just
want to sort of piggyback off the
previous points and really say something
real quick so the point on employment
rights
this is such a fundamental point like
in economics they distinguish between
you know structural frictional and sort
of cyclical unemployment right and
structural is when you sort of
technology changes and you're no longer
employed right like buggy whip drivers
or whatever right i'm sure they exist
still somewhere but the point is
the the the importance of employment is
not just something it's
the first time you meet someone you say
i am ilya i am a doctoral student right
it's literally the second like it's such
a big part of the identity that's sort
of just sort of saying hey you know
maybe there could be things that we can
come up with
these are very sort of tenuous things
people don't understand how important it
is second point um
there's a lot of philosophical work on
this anyway uh the second point is sort
of optimization i was thinking about
your example it's such a uh it's such an
important example like i can imagine
that your paper let's say in like 20
years there is
you get the perfect admissions
algorithm right all of the all of the
challenges have been addressed
would i still feel comfortable in the
knowledge that some algorithm is
deciding my
graduate school admission right even if
there is a perfect algorithm that
addresses all the issues it still is
there's something about it that sort of
i think a lot of ai and ml researchers
don't actually like address or like keep
in the question it's like at the
elephant in the room
i was i was like i love nietzsche and he
has a quote in uh
not spoken to he says the best way to
preserve something is to destroy it it's
a weird it's a weird quote but what he
says is you know once we sort of tackle
problems we're actually sort of uh we're
actually improving the the things that
underlie them right we're saying okay
these are the things that can be done to
improve you're perpetuating the systemic
injustice of the hierarchy of the
educational system anyway that's that's
sort of like a general sort of thing
we'll take chris
we might have to take these as comments
and yeah about it after the break that's
right so mine was picking backing off
with salami
before anyway because i was just
wondering if uh serena have you been
following the the [ __ ] the algorithm
protests in britain
you know it sort of came out and uh
uncovered um you know the cover
disrupted the sort of school year for
school leavers in high school and so uh
because people couldn't sit there exams
a-level exams um they had to sort of uh
use this algorithm to kind of you know
this is what your grades would have been
you know
and one of the key
uh variables that was used was a
historical performance of schools that
people have come from and so obviously
you know people who've come from
historically very privileged schools
eaton and whatever were you know tended
to do very well by the algorithm and
people who came from uh under privileged
uh uh schools uh did uh very badly you
know
and uh you know it's a really like
stupid algorithm you know um and it led
to these huge protests
um and i'm just saying it's interesting
you know uh
sort of the way these things work
there's a kind of way of
presencing these kind of like late and
sort of class uh tensions uh social
tensions gendered tensions particularly
that you're drawing attention to and
racialized tensions as well
um and but i think it's sort of a
challenge you know simply it's difficult
to kind of really optimize for this it's
a big ask to try to resolve these
tensions within an algorithm but it's
just something interesting for me to you
know how do you kind of like absorb as
you already are you know kind of
responding to those kinds of critiques
and how like that kind of tension plays
a part in the way you are you're
modeling these sort of problems yeah
just something interesting
chris and lastly jd and then keep it
brief jd and we can talk about it over
really enjoyed these talks um i think
really my question is the same as
peter's and chris's so it'll be short
what is the alternative to
using machine learning models in
graduated missions right is the
alternative as solemnly suggested like
somebody who's exhausted looking at the
end of the pile sort of having their own
biases being coded here and
you know in a sense like what is the use
of these algorithms in particular ways
tell us about the values that people
have like
it feels like what they're telling us is
that we don't know what we want and like
a lot of these
a lot of the problems that you're
describing are in many ways wicked
problems with many stakeholders and you
can't make everyone happy and all this
stuff you know graduate admissions is no
exception to that
and so like
it strikes me that the question that
we're like battering around the edges of
is actually far deeper than just like
you know is this an appropriate use of
machine learning but is it like
what do we actually want here you know
i don't have an answer to that question
obviously
yeah these new technological
developments i think one of the great
value of them is they're forcing a whole
lot of difficult questions in a lot of
different different ways i think that's
a
that's a great thing this has been a
wonderful panel and a really excellent
discussion this morning and please join
me in thanking our wonderful speakers
[Applause]
taking some